huge congratulations on the movie thank
you express how much I loved it Ben
first question for you obviously I want
to talk a little bit about incorporating
Michael Jordan in the movie especially
because I really loved how you
approached that was there any
workshopping or trial and error in the
writing and development phase to figure
out the right way to do that or is what
we see in the final film the plans since
day one the fact that he was not in it
is definitely the plan from day one
because I just think he's too big and
meaningful and famous and and Grand to
ever have the audience believe uh that
somebody else was him especially given
that he doesn't have the whole an actor
wouldn't have the whole movie to try to
flesh it out like you know I've seen it
done you know Denzel did it with Malcolm
X you know that thing where at the end
of the movie you're surprised that the
real Malcolm X we see the clip doesn't
look like Denzel but that just that the
opportunity wasn't wasn't available and
I thought it would undermine the movie
and also it's not it's really I didn't
want to to tax Michael use Michael's
image in that way but really tell a
story a kind of a fable about the people
around him and uh you know he just was
it's a story about the people who who
who are around somebody who's great and
who means that much to the world and I
felt like it was kind of more
interesting and more effective if all
the things that we remember about him
and that we have in our memories we
bring to it and imagine the imagination
is more powerful than anything you can
do as a filmmaker what you said in the
in your director statement was perfect
air is not Michael Jordan's story but
there is no story without him and you
feel it the way you Incorporated him I
was so impressed by that Chris for you
we only get to spend so much time with
Howard in the movie but I know that you
knew him and you also spoke to a whole
lot of people who know him well as well
so is there any like little detail that
maybe we don't see or hear about in the
final film but we can feel informing
your performance in the movie uh no I
think I tried to get it all all in those
scenes I was in and it was you know it
was like kismic you know this role was
meant for me me and Howard you know I
yeah similar I could pull from him I
like you know his personality he's a
really nice guy kind guy and yeah of
course he had me talk to so many people
and I tried to get his dialect down and
try to get his his kind-heartedness you
know Charles Barkley would tell me
stories about how he he mentored him and
so many other athletes so yeah I think I
think I tried to get I think we got it
all in there but he has a life story
coming so I know he'll get way more than
that coming soon yeah I had I had heard
you talk about that in another interview
I'd be really curious to see more of a
story yeah it was an incredible life
actually this is just a one little
sliver of who Howard white was he's an
extraordinary guy you get to make more I
will be here to watch it I have a little
bit of a big serious question for you
guys because I just loved seeing someone
choose deep authentic passion over what
one might deem the smarter business move
in this movie so over the course of your
careers can you give me an example of a
time when someone else recognized your
Vision passion and heart over business
and financial value and you made
something special because someone else
believed in you and gave you a shot
I mean like for me there's two kind of
defining moments one was when
um you know we were sold Good Will
Hunting as a script and everybody tried
to get us off of it as actors you know
wanted to get rid of us and and uh
Castle Rock initially this glosser and
and Rob Ryder and that company out Horn
uh Mark Schaffer they bought it and they
they allowed us to attached us as actors
and that that really changed everything
of course Robin and Gus you know going
along with that made a big deal and then
then there was really the you know I
have to say Amazon and this deal
recognizing you know ours equity and our
company and and kind of acknowledging
and allowing us to take the approach
that we want to take and give ourselves
a chance to approve this model was very
very meaningful because we wouldn't have
been able to do it uh had they not been
been open to that and uh so you know
this we had to Bear out but but I felt
that it was a a very very big risk and a
big deal and I hope that it really pays
off yeah and I think it's uh you know
like might be like something like Def
Comedy Jam when uh you know all the
producers saying I want you you know I
only had a certain amount of time you
know in my ACT but I want you to be on
this show and uh it was a really hot
series on that on HBO and they gave me a
shot to uh to do my thing and uh it that
really uh helped out my career I think I
love hearing it I love this movie I also
love your initiative with artist Equity
I can't wait to see everything else you
make under that Banner congratulations
to both of you thank you very much